Hey guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop
Everybody loves cookies and they can be even more fun when you get to choose
What shape they're in sometimes you can't find just the right shape of cookie cutter so today
We're going to see if we can make our very own cookie cutters using aluminum cans
These cookie cutters will be made using aluminum cans a little bit of tape and a little bit of hot glue
We also have a couple of tools that we're gonna use to cut and shape the metal sheets
We have our cookie cutter making supplies
We've got some cookie dough to test it out on so let's get started to begin
I just want the flat sheets of aluminum that I can get from these cans so I'm going to start by cutting off the top
Cutting down the side and then cutting off the bottom and use the utility knife just to get the cut started and then I'll switch
to scissors
As you can see it's an extremely ragged cut, but we'll smooth that out in a second
With our sheet of aluminum cut out and now let's try and get rid of the ragged edges if you have any sort of straight
Edge, you can use that will help make sure your cuts are nice and clean, and you have nice straight lines
It's much better now one side that's completely nice and straight now. I'm just going to do the same thing on the other side
The blade was cutting into the metal just a little bit of an angle and it sliced out this little spiral
If you prefer not to use a utility knife you can also mark off where you want it to cut and then just use a
pair of scissors
Cutting the metal with both utility knife and the scissors
Could leave a sharp edge or some burrs that you could cut yourself on so just to get rid of those really quick
Let's take some extremely fine grit sandpaper and go over the edge of our cam so we don't cut ourselves
There we go now that we have our pieces of can cut out the edges straightened and all of the sharp edges
Removed with some sandpaper. We're ready to start forming these into shapes to cut cookies for the next step
Let's cut off strips of the aluminum sheeting that are about one and a half inches wide
There we go now, we've got our strip, I'm just gonna quickly use the sandpaper again on the newly cut edge
Now I'm just going to mark every half inch on this inch and a half wide piece
So we're dividing it into three equal portions now
let's fold the top third down onto the second third this will reinforce our cookie cutter and make it a little bit stronger as we
Shape it lose the cap of my pen to sort of crease that down a little bit
Go we now have a strip of aluminum which is
Sturdier on the top and nice and thin on the bottom. Let's make a few more of those
There we go now
We've got several strips of our cut and reinforced strips of aluminum
now with the strips of metal what we want to do is bend them into the shape that we want our cookies to be I've
Got three different shapes here printed out, and I want to try and make cookies that match these shapes
Let's start with this star shape the goal is we're going to try to bend our aluminum sheets
To follow along the line that we have printed out now
I don't know if this one sheet of metal is going to be long enough to get around the whole pattern
but the nice thing is that if you run out you can take a second sheet and just
Nest it nicely into the first one
We'll then use a little bit of tape and a small dab of hot glue to secure the ends together
You can use my pen and just mark the next spot where I want to bend it that
Way I can take it off the paper
Hold it in my hands as I do the bending try bending it over my straight edge and see if that helps him
It makes a nice straight crease
One of the things you really want to watch out for is that you need to make sure that your creases are
perfectly perpendicular
To the direction of your metal if you accidentally make your fold to any sort of an angle you'll have a very hard time
Getting the bottom of your cookie cutter to stay flat
You can see that this strip of aluminum has run out and I haven't quite finished making my cookie cutter shape, so I'm going to
Take another piece of the aluminum attach it to this one and then just continue along the pattern
I'm going to use a small dot of hot glue just here in the seam to hold it together nicely
Now to reinforce it just a little bit more to make sure it doesn't pull apart
I'm almost going to use a little bit of this strong tape along the top
Just like that we have extended the size of our aluminum strip by double
Now I've clearly got too much metal strip right now
And I want to be able to line it up just right so it fits in here
So I'm first going to just give a rough cut right about there, and then I'll align it more perfectly after I do that
There we go we now have a nice star-shaped strip of metal now
Let's attach the ends here, so it holds itself together well instead of flopping around
If you do end up joining pieces of metal together check to make sure that the bottom is still nice and flush
If you have a little bit of a lip like I do here, you can just trim that off with a pair of scissors
Now at this point we have a star-shaped
Piece of metal that we should be able to press down into some cookie dough and give us a star-shaped cookie
Let's try out the exact same process with a couple other shapes
Now with this shape one piece of metal is pretty much the perfect size to go all the way around it
But I want to keep that point at the bottom of the heart shape and since I don't want to just tape these two together
I'm actually just going to take a small piece of another strip of metal and
Fit it onto both of them so we can keep that nice taper
You do have to be careful while pressing this together because the aluminium conducts heat pretty well
So it can heat up a lot if you're using a high-temperature glue these gloves are pretty thin
But they do stop my fingers from getting burned as I squeeze that together
Alright, that looks nice and attached then just for reinforcement. I'll put a strip of tape on the outside
And go nice heart shape
It's like curving this one, so I'm just going to try bending it around like ten
Looks like it's working pretty well all right. That's working alright. We just need a little patch a couple inches long to fill this out
Clearly too long of course, and you just going to do a rough cut when you measure better
That I think is a pretty good speech bubble
To test out your cookie cutters make or buy some sugar cookie dough prepare it as instructed and then start cutting them out
We get our shapes up onto a cookie sheet with have it deforming too much
Add a little flour we're gonna pretend. This is a spatula - not a cheese slicer
Flour helps
There we go, we've got our main cookie cutters
We've cut some cookies, and we've got those baking and while those are cooking
I actually went ahead to try and push the creative boundaries of how
Detailed of a cookie cutter you can make with this so I have made a king of random crown symbol cookie cutter you
Might notice, there's a little bit less detail in this crown than in the original logo
I'm not gonna be able to get all of those tiny little details into a cookie anyway
However to make sure I do have the little round points on the tip of the crown. I have this secondary little tube
I'm just gonna cut out a little circle at the top of each one so let's roll out a little bit more cookie dough and
See how well this thing works
And even just kind of lifting yourself out
Make sure all of the bits of the crown get pushed all the way down to the dough
Oh
Yeah, now let's take our little hole punch and cut out on top of the pack
Take off the extra dough pop these into the oven
Their shapes have puffed up quite a bit
Our first batch of shaped cookies is out of the oven I don't think this particular sugar cookie recipe is the very best
from making custom shapes because they did kind of deform a little bit in the oven and I know that's pretty natural for that to
Happen a little bit these ones seemed to puddle and move around a little bit more than some however
You can still see the shape. We've got hearts stars, and these little speech bubbles and you know what they taste pretty good, too
I'm gonna take one of our speech bubble cookies
And I'm gonna add some decorative frosting which is one of the best parts of sugar cookies
Wow, that is yellow frosting all right spread some frosting on our speech bubble cookie here
Now I'm gonna take just a little bit of this
frosting add some different food coloring and then pipe it out so we can have some speech in our speech bubble and
Mix up a little bit of frosting here in this cup and a few drops of glue
You can turn this yellow frosting into a dark green frosting
Got a little ziploc bag. We're gonna use that for piping out our frosting onto our speech bubble
This is of course not a real authentic piping bag
But I think it's going to work because we don't have all that much to right
Cut off a tiny bit of the corner
Well as I feared we definitely did lose some definition in those crowns now. It looks kind of more like a
jellyfish
inside a triangle
But that's alright the cookie cutter works great this particular cookie dough doesn't work amazingly
There you have it we have taken some soda cans cut them up into little strips of aluminum and folded them and molded them into
Just the right shape so we can use them as
Custom cookie cutters these things actually work really well they cut through the dough very nicely just because you have a thin metal edge
So it's really easy to get right through pick up a lot of detail and then they cook and you've got your shaped cookies this
Particular cookie dough does tend to deform a little bit, so you've got like a vague
Reminiscent shape of your cookies, but for the most part this worked really well
I'm pretty happy with it you can cut out your shapes decorate them with
Frosting right draw put sprinkles on them whatever you want to do however you like your cookies
That's level Point is fully customizing this project is a lot of fun obviously doesn't take many supplies
It's basically just some empty soda cans and then you can make your own custom cookies
This is a great project that you should do at home, or at a friend's house
Or you know wherever you make cookies grandma's house
Thanks guys for joining us for this project, and we look forward to the next one talk to you then
King of random cookie with sort of a deformed crown
Shape in there
Sure, there's everyone out there on YouTube who has their own
Cooking and baking channel is just laughing at me for doing this completely the wrong way
Hey guys
Thank you for your comments so many of you have really interesting
Suggestions for projects and experiments, and we love testing those out for you. I also wanted to say thank you for the great feedback
You're leaving for me and my team because we are all in this together, so thank you for being on our team